so today we are going to talk about
non-cdcl solvers this is the theme of
the session today
so cdcl solver have been a another
amazing accomplishment of the past
25 years i call it the sat revolution
but i've i've been on the record that as
much as the
cdcl have been successful uh there is a
bit of monoculture in the sad community
and we need to
look at other other type of solvers and
that's
what today's three speakers will tell us
about three
different uh type of solvers
and the first talk is by marane hule who
will talk about
such solver such solvers but a
non-non-cdcl focusing on smart versus
fast
or as some people call it a brainiac
versus the speed demon
go for it marian thank you
um i'm excited to talk with you about uh
look ahead solvers
look ahead was actually the topic of my
phd thesis
and it is something completely different
than cdcl
although it's not as powerful as cdc on
the industrial instances
it has quite some also applications and
some interesting reasoning
and i gladly want to kind of go over
some of these
cool techniques with you um
this talk uh we'll focus on on four
parts first i have a kind of a rather
large introduction
uh on sotbot focusing on on look ahead
and i think um the most cool thing i
think of look ahead is actually the
so-called local learning aspect
and frequently when i see other papers
now about look ahead
they kind of ignore this aspect there's
lots of
cool local learning that one can do
and i kind of want to kind of go over a
handful of these techniques
and at the end of this talk i want to
kind of show
how look ahead can be used in
for very hard and challenging problems
in combination with cdcl
which is known as cuban conquer
marcia already mentioned this and i
guess most of the audience is very aware
about this subtle revolution the
enormous breakthrough that we had in the
last 20 years when solving sod
up till the mid 90s we were only able to
solve formulas with up to say thousands
of variables and
thousands of clauses and today we can
solve
many problems arising from industry with
millions of variables and millions of
clauses
if you kind of look back to the early
south research say the
first 40 years of such research so from
the late 50s till the late 90s
it was all based on dpol and let me kind
of
because this is actually also one thing
that most shaytar told me
if you want to build an algorithm
you have to kind of decide whether you
want to focus on being smart
or being fast and typically you cannot
do both
because the data structures don't allow
you if you want to do something very
smart
you need very detailed data structures
and that prevents you from being fast
once it comes to satisfiability you also
actually have a second choice
you also have to decide whether you want
to focus on finding a solution
or trying to prove whether no solution
exists
and if you kind of summarize to say the
first 40 years
so the late 50 late 50s to the late 90s
in sub solving then almost all
approaches were focused
trying to be smart and trying to find a
solution
and um i think the the main breakthrough
actually came
when the the people decided okay
uh let's try to be fast and try to find
to refute a formula and actually a
satisfying assignment is just a counter
example that no such refutation exists
but there actually has been a lot of
cool work in those 40 years and also
later
um that are
already worth exploring and also have
have their own applications
and so this is most of most of that grew
to actually look ahead and i will talk
about this now
so first they're very short what is look
ahead
look ahead what it tries to do is it
tries to make
a binary search tree of the search space
and it tries to make the tree as small
as possible
how does this work in each node
of the search tree you pick a variable
and then you split it into two nodes
one where the variable's assigned to
true and the other one works assigned to
false
picking the right variable for the split
is very important
and can reduce the the search stream
sometimes by orders of magnitude
this approach with the right heuristics
is very effective on a broad range of
problems
although all of them tend to be
relatively small
say up to thousands of variables and
thousands of clusters its main weakness
because
the heuristics are very effective
however they are also expensive and if
you
deal with variables over formulas with
say a million variables this is
completely impossible because
these things are just too expensive
cdcl most of you probably know at least
the basics of it
it is not trying to be smart as in as
look ahead
picking the right decision all the time
but it tries to be fast
and so what it does it does very cheap
heuristics to pick a variable
and then assigns it simplify again a
simple
decision and only the reasoning starts
to really kick
in once you hit the conflict this
conflict is
turned into a clause which is added to
your database
and we continue right this has been
very effective on large problems which i
call
easy because sometimes the runtime of
the cdcl solver
is is linear even in case for
unsatisfiable ones
this is only possible if these problems
are easy
right so there are short proofs for
these formulas and cdcl really knows how
to
quickly find them one of the main
weaknesses of cdcl
is that it's very hard to paralyze
but i will actually at the end of this
talk talk about how we can combine
lookahead and cdcl for some
effective parallelism
something i briefly want to touch is
local search
local search is another solving paradigm
which is quite effective on the range of
problems
it starts with a full assignment and
then
it starts flipping the true values of
some variables until
satisfying assignments is found some
problems that take years with both
cdcl or look ahead or that combination
can be solved sometimes in seconds with
local search
local search has the same as property as
cdcl it's all the data structures are
really focused on trying to do
things fast
so although most of the people that
heard about santa are
aware of these extremely important
uh progress on industrial instances but
also
in the last couple of years there have
been a lot of progress
in solving long-standing open math
problems
using a combination of look ahead and
ctcl
and without these this combination
it would be impossible to solve these
problems efficiently
now let's go a little bit more into
detail how
lookahead works so look ahead is based
on
it builds a dpl3 which dates back to the
early 60s and i already mentioned it
it in it builds a binary search tree
and in each node of the search of of the
tree
you pick a variable which ideally splits
the space into
two much easier subterms
and at each step of the recursion you
first simplify the formula
with unit propagation you can also do
some additional stuff
and and then you do a split
and this this you repeat there are two
important heuristics here
the first one is which variable do we
pick
at each note in the third of in the tree
and the second one is which of the two
branches
are we going to explore first
if you always if the formula are
satisfiable and you pick
the right one you would just straight
walk to
a solution so it can be very beneficial
to
spend some time to to figure out
which branch might be the more
satisfiable one
and although i won't talk about it in
this talk because
uh it's only 30 minutes but you can do
awesome some
interesting ways to jump through the
search space or
through the tree to find the solution
fast using
look-ahead techniques
a very simple example so on the slide
there is
a formula with five clauses
if you would pick in this example x3 as
your first decision
then you have a small three with only
two leaf nodes
however if you for example pick a
variable x2
then the number of leaf nodes doubles
and so on this small example you see
that just picking
the wrong variable doubles the size in
practice
for hard problems it's picking the wrong
variables can actually result
in trees that are orders of magnitude
larger
compared to picking the right ones so
it's very important to pick
the right variables
in this in the to do for the splitting
i already use the word look ahead now
several times and most of you probably
don't know exactly what it is so let me
be very brief
on uh to give first a high level thing
here
the look ahead shots over is a dpol soft
solver
where looker heads are used to pick
the vari the decision variable and what
is a look ahead
a look ahead is you pick a variable
assign it to a true value
and then simplify it as much as possible
this is typically only done by unit
propagation
and then you do two important things the
first thing
is you measure the reduction and
there are many ways to measure the
reduction for example you can measure
the reduction of the size of the formula
the number you can the reduction in the
number of variables i will
briefly talk about this more on some
later slides
and then what you can also do and what i
what i figured out in the in the last
kind of decade
is that possibly the most important
thing
what you can need to do afterwards is to
learn
as much as possible and
the learning that is here is completely
different than cdcl
and this is what i call local learning
and
most of the middle part of this talk
will be on
local learning techniques once you've
finished
the local learning then you backtrack
and you do a look ahead for another
variable
yeah so this is the the high level steps
of look ahead
now let's look at an example so on the
bottom of the slide you see
a formula f learning
and i will use this formula throughout
the remainder of this stock
and how does a look-ahead work so we
start by picking a variable in the truth
assignment
for example x2 and false and so we
assign
x2 to false and what you see now here is
that
this clause becomes unit
all the literals except for one are
falsified
and so you are forced to make x1 false
this in turn makes this a unit clause
and therefore forces x 6
to be false as well and now
this clause becomes unit forcing
x3 to be true
afterwards there's no simplifications
possible anymore
and so that part of the look ahead is
over
but now we need to do the next step
which is
measure the reduction
so on the next slide i will show you
this and then we will talk a lot about
learn if possible
now so this is exactly the same formula
and the assignment of the look ahead on
the prior slide
and now the question is how are we going
to
do the measurements so one way
is for example is to count the number of
satisfied clauses in this case
we have eight clauses and seven of them
are satisfied so there's a lot of
reduction if you
use that metric you can also look at the
number of implied variables in this case
this is
three of them
the number of satisfied clauses is tends
to be very bad metric
the number of implied variables is quite
a bit better
but the best method map
typically in practice is to count and
actually
weigh the number of new clauses and new
other clauses that
are reduced but not satisfied
in this example this is only the clause
x4 x5 or x6
this one has been reduced from a ternary
clause to a binary clause
and what you do and look ahead typically
is you count
the number of of reduced clauses and
then
uh make the shorter clauses more
important and actually you also
put a lot of weights in there and the
weights you can
maybe view as what is the probability
that the random assignment would
satisfy the uh the reduced clause
and the and this heuristic
is uh is now used in most of the
state-of-the-art softwares
you do some weighing of the
reduced clauses so now we have all
aspects of the of the look ahead
architecture which is on the top
we have we built our dpil tree
and in each node before kind of deciding
which is the decision variable we look
at the simplified formula
and then we do look ahead on all the
variables or subset of the variables
and the look ahead is we assign it to a
true value
simplify the formula and do some
measurements so for example
the numbers over here show for example
the reduced not satisfied clauses
and these are the heuristic values and
then
we need to combine them because you
pick a variable and not a literal and
the best practice is actually to just
multiply these numbers
and the highest multiplication is the
one that you
pick but notice here
is that if you do a look ahead sometimes
the look ahead can result in a conflict
so
if we assign x3 to false it can result
in a conflict
which means that all satisfying
assignments must have x3 to true
and this is actually this the kind of
easiest way of local learning
and local learning is very important to
pick the right decision and so although
we can compute these values
in the first kind of iteration over all
the variables
it is very important to first do a loop
a lot of local learning
which improves the accuracy of the
heuristic which in turn makes the tree
much smaller
okay now let me focus on the local
learner
so we all so what ctcl is doing is
it hits a conflict and adds a clause to
the formula
and this clause is logically implied by
the formal
lookahead is not doing any of this kind
of global learning
the clauses that are added are only
valid for that
note of the search and all its children
and so what we're going to do is we're
only going to learn clauses typically
units
and binary clauses that are valid for
that note and everything below it
and because they're only valid at this
point in the search
it means that if as soon as we backtrack
we have to
remove them all
and this also makes the data structures
much more complicated because you
need to do a lot of accounting which
clauses are valid where
let me first talk about the easiest part
and we already talked about it which is
the field literals
so we do a look ahead on l was true if
it results in a conflict
then we know that l has to be false and
all for in
all satisfying assignments
if both the look ahead on l and the look
at or not l are for our
failed literals then we actually found a
dead end situation and that note is
and we need to backtrack this notion
of field literal can also be generalized
to the so-called double look ahead and
double look ahead is we actually pick
two variables
and two truth values and then do unit
propagation and see whether they result
in a conflict
for example our learning formula
we assign x4 to false x x
6 to true and then by unit propagation
x 1 has to be true x 2 has to be true
x 3 has to be true and then we have our
falsified clause and this means that we
can learn the clause
x4 or not x6
look uh this double look ahead is very
uh
can be extremely effective on some
problems but
notice that this is very
expensive right because we need to pick
two variables
so the complexity of doing it for all
possible
assignments for two ones is cubic
because also the unit propagation
is can be linear in the number of
variables
so it can be very expensive but for some
problems it is ignore
very effective but for others it's
extremely costly
[Music]
so jacob um let me let me do the
what what is the question uh it's
obvious why we cannot learn
properly a globally valid clause yeah so
so jakob mentioned that of course the
locally learned clauses we could add
them as globally once by
putting the prefix in there
but at least in practice so oliver
implemented this in his soul for the
okay solver
but in practice this is not very
effective so the clauses typically
because you pick the right decisions
that
they're no longer valid elsewhere
now let's talk about another
local learning technique which is called
hyper binary resolution
so we have a variable x prime
that occurs in many binary clauses
and it occurs there with the literals
not x1 to not
xn and we also have a long clause
x or x1 to xn
if you're going to look what happens
with unit propagation that if we make
x prime false then the unit clauses all
propagate
x 1 to false x2 to false x and 2 false
and afterwards the long clause becomes
unit
because all the literals x1 to xn become
false
which forces x to be true
right so if we have this situation then
we we observe that not x prime implies
x
and this happens by unit propagation but
the interesting thing to notice here
is that if we make x false then
just the long clause would
reduce to a clause just one shorter and
there's no unit propagation
and so what hyperbinary resolution does
is it picks
all these binary clauses and the long
clause and
by resolution merges it into a single
step into a binary clause
x or x prime and after adding this
binary clause we have x naught x
in implies x prime
and we're actually going to find these
hyperbinary resolvents using
uh unit propagation so we do unit
propagation
so we start with x2 and then
we have the unit x1 comes from this
binary clause
x6 comes from this binary clause and x3
comes from that binary clause
and for all of the ones that are not
implied by an x2 liter
binary clause we can add a hyperbinary
resolvent
this one or this one and
the latter one is the most effective one
because
this one so the
this one is due to a binary clause but
this one
is due to a ternary clause and would
improve the unit propagation
during future look-aheads
now another technique is called
necessary assignments so we do
look ahead on axis x is true x1 is true
which would imply x2 x3 and x4 to true
and now we do another look ahead with
x12 false
which would imply by unit propagation
x6 is false and x3 is true notice that
in both cases x3 is forced to true
so either we we assign x1 to true
or if we assign x1 to false we both
have x3 is true so therefore x3 has to
be true in all assignments
satisfying a science
in case we do hyperbinary resolvence we
also would find
that x3 to false would be a field
literal
but if we don't do this actually we
wouldn't find this
but doing necessary assignments is
actually
a way to find this much more quickly
another technique is
alter keys and alter keys it might is
this is a bit more exotic
an altar key is an assignment that
satisfies
uh all the clauses that are taxed by it
uh example is the pure literal
which there's no complement of it so if
you assign the periodical true
then only clauses get satisfied also
satisfying assignment is a
alter key because all the clauses are
satisfied so clearly also all the
clauses that are taxed are satisfied
interesting alter keys are the ones
actually in between
pure literals and satisfying assignments
and the nice thing that you can do is
if you find an alter key all the clauses
that are touched
by the alter key you can take out and
the resulting formula
is satisfiability equivalent to the
original one
then there's also this notion of the one
alter key
and a one alter key is all clauses
except for one are reduced are satisfied
so there's one clause that is reduced
but not satisfied all the other ones
are satisfied
now we do for example a look ahead on
x1 which results in the assignment that
x2 x3 x4 are also assigned to true
notice that all the clauses that are
touched by the assignment have
satisfied literals a green literal and
therefore the formula is satisfiability
equivalent to
x5 or not x6
and this technique can also help to
reduce the computational cost
on unsatisfiable instances a little
small side note here
is that look ahead can have can quickly
solve two subformulas by
simply doing only look-aheads you never
have to branch
either a look ahead results in an altar
key
or and then you can force the literal to
be true
or look ahead results in a field literal
and you can assign it to false
and um yes let me because i'm kind of
um a bit short on time so let me
first finish the talk and then we can
talk about
uh a bit more about the
the the aspects here that we go beyond
resolution
another cool thing here and this is
actually much more effective than
than altar keys because altar keys are
kind of rare
the one other key learning so now we
assign x true to true
if it took to false sorry this implies
x1 to false x6 to false
and x3 to true now
we have a one other key
notice that this clause is the only
clause that has been
reduced but not satisfied
yeah now the question is how can we do
any learning here right because if we
had an author key
we could just take all the clauses out
right but what can we do here
the observation here is that if
x4 would have been true
then the assignment x2 false would have
been an alter key
right because xs4 would have taken this
clause out
and therefore if you were moved excite
x2 to
false this would have been an alter key
and the same holds for
x5 if x5 would have been true
then x2 to false would have been an
altar key
and as a consequence you can
learn the binary clauses the one author
key clauses
not x2 or not x4 or not x4
2 or not x5 so x4 implies not x2
and x5 implies in the texture and
the one alter keys actually happen very
frequently so while the altar keys
hardly happen
one alter keys frequently happened and
you can do this
local learning right so this rounds up
the
local learning aspect of this talk
so it is very important to look ahead
solvers because the local learning
really also improves the accuracy of the
heuristics
and thereby making the tree smaller
and some of these techniques are also
used in
in cdcl solvers for pre-processing and
in-processing
now let me briefly remark some remarks
about
cuban conquer so although
lookahead is not effective on large
formulas
because things are expensive you can
actually use
uh look ahead in combination with cdcl
to solve very hard formulas this is what
we call
cube and conquer and what does coupon
conquer do it builds
the dpl tree to
some level and then for all the leaf
nodes in the dpr
outreach at some cutoff level
we're going to call
a cdcl solver and
so we have we split our formula f
into uh n different
sub formulas the leaf nodes at some cut
in the dpl3
and then we solve them effectively using
cdcl
and for several problems
so i've been showing this on some
mathematical problems but also some
industrial problems
we can have linear time speed ups
even with thousands of cores
and for example this technique has also
been recently integrated
in the smt solver c3
i won't have time to re to go into
detail here
but let me briefly explain what i think
is going on
because cuban conquer we frequently
witness
super linear time speed ups how is this
possible
so what how i see look ahead so look
ahead is really good
in able if so if there are global
arguments
uh why the formula is unsatisfiable then
you need to make a good global split at
some point
after doing enough splits the formula
there becomes some local argument
by the formulas unsatisfied in case
there's a local argument why the
formulas are unsatisfiable you shouldn't
do a global split
because then the argument will be there
in both of the branches
and so what you need to do in order to
get the
cube and conquer effective is you split
until
a short refutation exists or at least
heuristically
you expect it to be there and then you
call the cdcl solver
and the cdcl software will find you the
local
conflict uh quickly
and so the plot shows uh kind of that
you get these this this feed up
uh more and more and increases but at
some point for this problem
the splitting costs become so expensive
that the splitting is more expensive
than
than the total cdcl cost
now to conclude so i presented
some aspects of the look ahead
architecture
look ahead tries to be smart instead of
trying to be
fast and uh it is
tries to be smart both by picking the
right variable and an aspect that i
really didn't talk about march is
it tries to be smart by picking the
right branch
this is very effective on small and hard
formulas and also can be used
very effectively for some heart problems
in combination with cdcl
so it's important that we have these
effective splits
and a very important aspect of this is
the local learning which i discussed
something i didn't have time to discuss
is that you really need to kind of
massage your data structures in order to
do this all efficiently
but this is uh one of the the key things
to make
look ahead effective in practice
okay that concludes my talk i see lots
of questions
um more say how are we going to do this
um
i'll pick the last one karen what would
you like to say or comment or ask
sure um my question was it looks like
i mean look ahead what's done in earlier
solvers i forget the name of the solver
but this guy from sweden
so there's bfs and there's dfs
uh cuban conquer does bfs followed by
depth first search which is cdc health
can you view
uh this as a just one point on the
spectrum of how to combine depth first
versus breadth first and learning in
these most different styles
um what do you mean by this just one
aspect or because there's many other
ways of doing this
you you me yeah i'm saying instead of
just doing like in human conquer you do
look ahead and then cdcl what if you do
a little bit of look ahead
do a little bit of cdc l and then stop
cdcl and do more
look ahead and then do c's do um
cds and so on so you you interleave
breadth first and depth first
depending on what you're learning and
what's happening in the search space
yeah so we have a paper let
maybe augment the question suppose that
we look at this this uh
the cuban conquer and look ahead it's
just another
kind of use set of we have arsenal of
heuristics
and we decide dynamically to use them as
appropriate
rather than make a decision upfront are
we are going to use cdcl
or we're going to do look ahead
yeah so actually i i had a paper
i think uh quite some years ago with uh
um a student uh in delft
which we which we called uh concurrent
cube and conquer
where we had uh
cdcl software always running in parallel
uh with with the look ahead so we in
every node we
let the cdcl software run on the same
problem and the look ahead solver tries
to figure out the best split
and the first one that actually finishes
kind of returns
and that was reasonably effective
although
[Music]
it didn't give a major improvement
and also armin has an implementation in
tringling
where also kind of this combination uh
is trying to do it as effective as
possible in practice and
triggering has been quite effective in
several of the such competitions
so tringling well splits the search
space
lose using look-aheads but then
rinse the sub-problems using cdcl
if that if they cannot be solved within
a certain time limit
all of them are split again and and this
is repeated so this is actually what
what you kind of suggested
is what uh happens in the silver trinity
right i mean so it's been done i mean
i'm just curious i'm intrigued by the
fact that
you know you can learn um in a local
context something that might be
extremely helpful
in in you know you know either proving
unsaid or finding a sad
and the indications of what is happening
in that part of the search space
uh could actually uh inform whether you
want to do
further look ahead or further you know
cdcl
again you know what you said at the
beginning which is smart not fast you
know forget about
you know being fast now but you know is
that that seems to be unexplored yet
you know exactly where you want to do
this switch from
one uh way of doing things to the other
way
yeah but in to some extent you can also
see the in processing also as
as a bit of this right in processing
does feel literal detection and other
other things that you might do in a look
ahead solver and so
you might kind of incorporate lots of
these look ahead techniques actually in
an in processing phase of the cdcl
solver
right so you don't do any of the
splitting but you only
take the local learning part which in my
experience is one of the most effective
things also
of look ahead techniques oliver would
like to make a comment
may um so on this question of making it
dynamic so i think that's extremely
important
and i believe that in
the look ahead solvers has is currently
should have a better chance of of
getting a good sort of theoretical
handle on it
because so it's inherently simpler you
have all these
processes related to a tree growth
and you have it and the and the solver
measures anyway a lot of data which is
underutilized yet
it's all of that look-aheads and so on
there's a lot of data
uh which i believe um and i'm working on
that
we could to make much more focus with
that and then definitely so this
interleaving of these different
techniques so kind of
the look ahead perhaps more at the
planet
as marine perhaps said the look ahead
has more the planning oversight is less
good possibly this
is solving the problem but it has a
better statistical overview and this
kind of
uh combination especially also
said so so that in the future i believe
there's there's a good chance
because the look ahead heuristics we
understand somewhat better
i i think quite a bit better than the
cdcl heuristics